[音楽]
私は15年以上の会社勤めの後3年前に起業した
まだまだ駆け出しの起業家です
今10歳ともうすぐ6歳の子供がいます
家族や周りの人たちに守られてきたおかげで大きな苦難もなく逆にドラマティックな
ネタがないので最初に謝っておきます
最近ちょっと意義のあることができたかなぁというのが
パパちゃんを抱っこしながらでも学べる子連れ mba を立ち上げたことです
6年前赤ちゃんだった次男を抱っこしながらこんな会議室で
同じく赤ちゃん連れの仲間と集まりました
そこに大学の先生や実も彼を招いて最新のビジネスが学べる勉強会を始めました
では赤ちゃんでふさがっていても頭を支えるんです
そこから始まった子連れ mba
最近ではオンラインで関西以外からも参加できて伸び3000人近くが来てくれるよう
になりました
ここに参加する少なくとも数百人の人生をちょっぴり楽しくしたり
変えるきっかけにはなったかなと思います
でもこの活動もともと社会貢献しようと思って始めたわけでもなく
育休中の c さなきっかけから始まりました
育休中であってもなくても
赤ちゃんとの生活って案外過酷なんです
赤ちゃんは抱っこから下ろすとすぐなくし毎日トイレもお風呂も猛ダッシュです
夜は4巻で親は3時間以上連続して寝られません
そんな中でもいく今日が終わってからの自分のキャリアがとっても心配
そこでふと思いついて育休中にちょっと赤ちゃんを抱っこしているんですがその
赤ちゃんを抱っこしながらスマホ片手に友達でメッセージを送りました
赤ちゃん連れで勉強会惜しい
面白がってくれた友達が友達を呼んでまたその友達が友達を呼んでどんどんどんどん
仲間が増えました
最初の勉強会にはほぼ初対面の15人が集まりました
正確には15人の大人と通行人の赤ちゃんの合計30人
なかなか賑やかです
そこから企画や広報などてつだってくれる仲間が出てきてさらに人が増えました
そして私の行く今日が終わってからも活動を続けたい
そう言ってくれる仲間も出てきて
これまで100人以上が運営に携わってくれました
そんな中私がやってきたのは単にん赤ちゃんを抱っこしながらとか
通勤電車の中でスマホでずっとメッセージを送り続けただけです
最初こんなのって来てくれるかなスルーされないかな
コア5をやっていました
でも何度も失敗しながらもそこから学んでは行動する
これを繰り返していくととにかく思ったことは行動に移す
これが癖になって体にシマジ染み付いてきました
アブ職場でおかしいと思ったことがあったので正直に行動したところちょっとやり過ぎ
ちゃったのかほとんどクビ同然で退職することになりました
でもそれがきっかけで起業しました
初めて立ち上げたのはお子さん連れの家族に優しいインバウンド観光サービス
残念ながら今海外から日本に自由に人が来ることができないのでいったんこのサービス
を停止しています
そんな状況でも私はそこまで不安でもないんです
それに比べて会社で働いていた時はいつも心の奥に不安を抱えていました
それはゴールモデルや目指す姿は分からない
そんな不安です
この道は正しいのかなそもそも自分はどこに向かっているんだろう
そんなぐるぐるーとした不安を常に持っていました
でも今ではこんなふうは全くありません
なぜならば先の姿や道筋が今は明確に見えなくても自分の一つひとつの行動が確実に道
を開いていることが分かっているから
ある時子連れ mba に来ていただいた大学の先生から比較的新しい企業についての
理論を聞いてはっとしました
普段私たちは目的を設定してそこからの逆算からで行動することがよくあります
会社でも目標とそこに向かう計画をつくって実行する
その繰り返しです
一方熟達した起業家27人の調査では
彼らに共通する行動の特徴はそうではありませんでした
樹表のような不確実性が高い中では必ずしも
目的ありきで考えなくとも良い
まず自分自身を基点として自分の御土居
そしてできることから行動する
その際に偶然の出来事をチャンスとして捉えて周りの人や組織をどんどん巻き込んで
いく
そんな特徴が熟達した起業家たちには共通していたといいます
その証拠に今成功している会社で創業時は全く違う授業をしていた会社も少なくあり
ません
私が最初にお世話になった任天堂
もともとは花札屋さんでした
任天堂と書いています
この任天堂も昔何度も倒産の危機があったと聞きます
でも斜面にある通り運を天に任せて
機器からは学んで時には方向転換をしてその行動の積み重ねによって今の姿があります
実は個人のキャリアの8割は予想しない偶然の出来事によって決定される
そういう研究結果もあります
この偶然じっと待っていても出会えません
偶然に出会うのにも偶然をチャンスに変えるのにもあなたの行動が必要です
この行動に1人2人でも友達を巻き込むと
私の友達への1本のメッセージから始まった
子連れ mba のように
一人から二人三人10人100人とどんどん巻き込まれる人が増えていて
とてもたくさんの人を楽しませることができるようになるかもしれません
今日私がこの話を皆さんにしたのは
この中で一人でも多くの人に自分の思いを行動に移してほしいからです
あなたが学生さんであっても社会人であっても心の奥人
何か些細な思いや違和感
お持ちだと思います
その思いや違和感蓋をしたり
ずーっとそれどうしようかなどうしたらいいのかな
考えているだけではなくて
ほんの小さなことでもいい何か行動してほしい
会社で思った通りにやりすぎると
私のように首になっちゃうかもしれないのでそれは気を付けて下さい
でも将来何が起こるか分からない今会社が今後どうなるかもわからないしそれはそれで
いいかもしれません
そこまでしなくても
会社や日常と全く違う新しい場所にほんの一歩でも足を踏み入れてみる
そんなコードも素晴らしいと思います
このイベントが終わって2周日常に戻られた
一話を聞いたな
それで決して終わらないでください
これをきっかけにちょっぴり勇気を出して気になってた活動会イベントに参加してみ
たり
そこまでしなくても感想お友達にシェアしてみる
それだけでもいい
何か行動をしてみてください
私にはぼんやりとこれからの子どもたちのために今の世界をほんのちょっとでも良くし
ていきたい
そんな思いがあります
今の世の中最高のものかと言われると決してそうではありません
会社や組織では正直女性が子育てをしながら能力を発揮して働ける職場本当に少ない
です
この関西をはじめ首都圏以外ではこれが現状です
社会システムでも国内だけを考えてみても
子どもの貧困や一生懸命頑張っているシングルマザーが困窮している状況
本当に理不尽なことがたくさんあります
今から100年前でも考えてみると女性には選挙権もありませんでした
経済格差はもっと酷くて働いている子供もたくさんいました
そこから社会は少しずつは良くなっています
もそうやって社会を変えてきたのは突然スーパーマンが助けに来てくれた
そんなわけではありません
社会を変えるのはいつでも私やあなたのような普通の人間
私たちの一つ一つの行動の積み重ねです
あなたの心の奥にある些細な思いや違和感
本当に小さくてもいいぜひ行動に移してみてください
そんな小さな行動の積み重ねが
あなたの未来を創っていきます
そして今よりももっともっと良い世界をつくっていく
そう信じています
ありがとうございます